bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo analyse vous commencez à
avoir l'habitude nous allons nous
concentrer sur le nouvel épisode de la
saison 2 de loky l'épisode 3 et
franchement quel épisode de fou il y a
tellement de mystères de questions nous
avons plein de choses à dire dites-moi
vous en commentaire ce que vous avez
pensé de l'épisode quel a été votre
moment préféré ou tout simplement si
vous voulez partager vos idées sur ce si
vous êtes prêts je vous propose que l'on
commence nous sommes du point de vue de
Ravon rensleayer cette dernière si vous
vous rappelez bien a été orientée à la
fin de la première saison par Miss minut
sous les indication de celui qui demeure
à prendre un certain chemin ce chemin
nous en sommes désormais témoins c'est
l'année
1868 à Chicago dans le flux temporel
sacré l'univers 616 la réalité
principale là-bas ravona et Miss minut
vont faire une action qui va changer le
cours de l'histoire donner le manuel du
TVA à un Variant enfant de celui qui
demeure moi je vous avoue à ce moment
précis quand j'ai découvert l'épisode
j'ai un petit peu pété mon crâne si vous
connaissez un peu le personnage de Kang
l'un des fondamentaux hein qui le
caractérise fortement c'est qu'il vient
du futur et plus exactement du 30e
siècle c'est quelque chose d'assez
principal concernant le personnage car
cela accentue sa dangerosité si le
personnage vient du futur il connaît
donc le pass
l'histoire de l'humanité ou encore des
Avengers une nécessité pour un voyageur
temporel et un conquérrent puis surtout
de l'autre côté cela démontre aussi sa
puissance puisqu'il a accès à des
technologies et du savoir encore inconnu
pour nous être du 21e siècle et je ne
vous raconte même pas quand il atteindra
l'an 4000 par conséquent voir Kang
enfant dans le 19e siècle de l'univers
616 la réalité que nous suivons depuis
le début bah il est est assez facile de
commencer à se poser des questions par
la suite quand nous repassons du point
de vue de Loki et Mobius en quête de
Miss minut et de ravona nous passons de
l'année
1868 à l'année
1893 sauf que cette fois-ci nous sommes
dans une branche du flux temporel sacré
ce qui correspondait d'ailleurs à la
signature laissée par le P temporel de
ravona en vrai inutile de chercher bien
loin avec l'anachronisme provoqué par la
présence du manuel du TVA dans les mains
d'un enfant du passé c'est forcément la
naissance d'un Nexus qui donne donc
naissance à une branche soit un univers
alternatif en 1883 c'est la foire
internationale de Chicago nous y
rencontrons Victor timely l'enfant de
1868 qui a désormais bien grandi et ce
dernier a comme il semblait prévu
appréhendé et utilisé à fond le fameux
manuel du TVA bien évidemment ayant
besoin du personnage que ce soit pour
son AA temporelle afin de sauver le cœur
temporel du TVA ou bien VI mettre en
place le véritable plan de celui qui
demeure qui mènera à son retour Loki
Mobius ravona et Miss minut souhaite
s'approprier le variant au passage nous
avons pu être témoins d'une scène
rappelant le manque d'égalité que Loki
subit depuis toujours dans sa famille
lui qui a toujours souhaité être légal
de Thor qui lui au contraire est
toujours placé sur un piédestal nous
avons même une petite référence ici à
baldeur le demi-frère de Thor bien moins
populaire on ne va pas se mentir mais
qui pour temp prend la place de Loki
également nous retrouvons la même
dualité qui a opposé Loki et Sylvie dans
le dernier épisode de la première saison
face à celui qui demeure à cause de sa
vie de fugitive ruiné par le TVA et plus
particulièrement rensleyer et par
extension celui qui demeure sylvie est
devenue obsessionnelle avec la vengeance
mais finalement à la fin de l'épisode
elle semble raisonne dans le même cas de
figure que la fin de loky saison 1
sylvie a le moyen d'assassiner un
variant de celui qui demeure mais cette
fois-ci elle l'épargnera et concernant
ravona sylvie a juste compris qu'elle
voulait le pouvoir le fameux trône du
TVA situé à la fin des temps sauf que
Sylvie a déjà anéanti cet objectif bref
rentrons clairement à partir de
maintenant dans les véritables questions
qui nous intéresse en vérité il y a
plein de possibilités à voir ce que
Marvel nous proposera et je suis très
curieux en attendant moi je vais vous
expliquer ma vision et mon avis
qu'est-ce qui se cache derrière Victor
timely bon tout d'AB bord il y a cette
giga révélation que le personnage est un
enfant des années 1860 et en plus dans
le flux temporel sacré l'univers 616
principal au départ je me suis demandé
si Marvel n'était pas en train d'adapter
en parti le père de rid Richards
Nathaniel Richards dans le Lord de
Marvel Nathaniel Richards 616 est le
père de rid alias Monsieur fantastique
et il a vécu durant la première moitié
du 20e siècle avant de devenir un très
grand voyageur temporel c'est lui qui a
ramené la paix par exemple dans le 31e
siècle de l'univers 6311 l'univers
d'origine de Kang le Conquérant lui
aussi appelé Nathaniel Richards quand il
n'était encore du coup qu'un
scientifique mais voilà en réalité c'est
très farfelu comme idée cela ne
correspond pas mais je souhaitais quand
même le souligner en revanche là où nous
pouvons trouver des réponses
possiblement c'est concernant l'origine
de Victor
dans les comics dans l'idée d'établir le
passé pour orienter l'avenir un variant
de kangle conquérant va décider de
s'implanter au début du 20e siècle sous
l'identité Victor timely afin de
développer la technologie et le savoir
dans cette are du progrès scientifique
par conséquent le développement des
États-Unis est intimement lié aux
actions de Kang et c'est quelque chose
qui lui servira dans le futur c'est le
palmarès de cette identité Victor tamle
ne sert qu'à ça à la base implémenter le
passé pour définir et acquérir le futur
maintenant si nous retournons dans le
MCU nous pouvons voir que cette utilité
a changé pour nous proposer autre chose
en fait nous le comprenons assez bien si
l'enfant n'avait pas reçu le manuel du
TVA il n'aurait jamais développé des
inventions aussi poussées et c'est ce
qui donne justement nessence au Nexus
que nous avons exploré néanmoins ce
variant fait partie du plan de celui qui
demeure alors quel est son but en vrai
déjà il faut rappeler quelque chose de
précis c'est que le flux temporel sacré
est la création de celui qui demeure si
tout est prédestiné c'est parce que lui
l'a voulu c'est parce que cela fait
partie de son plan du coup moi je vois
qu'une seule solution possible
concernant Victor si Marvel respecte les
comics et ce qu'a déclaré celui qui
demeure dans l'oki sur le 30e siècle
Victor ne devrait pas être originaire du
19e siècle ce qui veut donc dire qu'il a
été placé là à cette période
volontairement mais du coup si cet
enfant issu du 30e siècle a été placé
dans le passé pourquoi cela n'a pas créé
de Nexus et bien justement car le flux
temporel sacré est la création de celui
qui demeure c'est lui qui décide ce qui
est prévu ou ce qui ne l'est pas
rappelez-vous du voyage dans le temps
des Avengers ravona nous le soulignait
bien leur cast temporel était prévu
c'est pourquoi il n'y a pas eu de Nexus
à cause de l'action de voyager dans le
temps et ramener les pierres du coup à
partir de là il y a pour moi deux
possibilités concernant Victor timely
soit il s'agit véritablement de celui
qui demeure jeune à l'aube de son
évolution et dans ce cas il a été placé
par son lui plus vieux pour un jour
déclencher le plan permettant de le
remettre sur le trône soit il s'agit
d'une simple cartouche un Variant qui a
pour but de préparer le terrain entre
guillemets au véritable celui qui
demeure mais il y a également un autre
élément intéressant à souligner une
autre possibilité en quelque sorte mais
nous en reparlerons un peu plus tard
l'élément principal qu'il faut retenir
concernant Victor timely dans le MCU
c'est qu'il est menoté et prisonnier du
passé et ce pour une bonne raison
l'accès à la technologie en fait c'est
logique celui qui demeure se connaît il
connaît ses variants il sait comment il
fonctionne si sa personne a accès à de
la technologie futuriste à des moyens
lui permettant de parcourir le multivers
ou de voyager dans le temps c'est là
qu'il peut devenir dangereux et causer
les pires atrocités la preuve en est
avec ce que nous raconter celui qui
demeure à la découverte de nouveau monde
de nombreux variants y ont vu des moyens
de conquête d'accumuler de la puissance
et du pouvoir en bloquant Victor dans le
passé c'est un moyen lui permettant
d'apprendre tranquillement dans son coin
sans répercussion derrière à cause de la
pauvreté de l'époque et du manque de
moyens Victor le souligne lui-même même
son potentiel est inutile il ne peut
développer que des prototypes l'humanité
n'est pas assez avancée et d'ailleurs
c'est comme si il n'était pas à sa place
durant cette période soulignant donc
cette idée qu'il a été placé là déjà
rien que ça c'est vraiment très fort
plus que ce que celui qui demeure nous
déclarait il ne manipule pas seulement
nos héros et l'histoire il manipule
aussi celle de ces variants et ça c'est
quelque chose de très comic accurate le
Kang principal par exemple a déjà
travaillé avec d'autres versions de
lui-même pour les exploiter secrètement
avant de les tuer derrière ou même tout
simplement Immortus la version finale du
personnage le maître du temps il
influence continuellement la vie d'un
Kang choisi pour lui faire emprunter le
même chemin afin qu'il devienne lui-même
un jour le seul et unique Immortus parmi
tous les variants qui eux s'entre
déchire là du coup nous arrivons à une
question concrète qu'en est-il du
véritable libre arbitre lre nos héros ne
semblent pas tant s'en rendre vraiment
compte surtout quand on regarde ravona
et Miss minut mais chacun a son rôle à
jouer dans le plan de celui qui demeure
je vous parlais d'une autre possibilité
un élément à souligner tout à l'heure et
bien je pense que c'est le moment de
l'amener on ne sait pas vraiment quel
avenir aura Victor timely
personnellement je ne pense pas qu'il
s'agisse de celui qui demeure à en
devenir pour de multiples raisons hein
c'est mon avis mais je peux me tromper
par exemple j'ai envie d'amener cet
élément mais pour souligner souvent la
différence entre les variantes du
personnage Jonathan majors utilise
toujours un acting différent c'est
peut-être qu'un détail mais il peut
avoir son importance celui qui demeure
possède sa personnalité Kang dans
kantumania était très u de lui-même et
cholérique dans la scène postgénérique
chaque variant ne possède pas la même
façon de s'exprimer et c'est aussi le
cas avec Victor timely qui bégay et
reprend ses mots à plusieurs reprises
quand il s'exprime soulligne an donc sa
différence face à ses autres lui-même
néanmoins en réalité je pense que l'idée
principale qu'il faut garder en tête
c'est que celui qui demeure ne n'est pas
celui qui demeure mais le devient il est
forgé à devenir ce qu'il deviendra avant
de mourir il a mis en place les
conditions au sein de ce chaos des
multiples branches pour orienter un
autre luit en devenir mais ce n'est pas
dit que Victor soit cette option ou du
moins soit cette seule option sa seule
cartouche et même pire que ça on nous
parle de guerre multiverselle depuis un
long moment une guerre que veulent à
tout prix éviter nos héros mais bien au
contraire il y a de très très grandes
chances que ce soit eux avec leurs
actions comme par exemple permettre à
timely d'accéder au TVA qui vont
déclencher la guerre multiverselle
guerre multiverselle qui dans le fond
est nécessaire c'est une obligation que
cela arrive pour que celui qui demeure
arrive sur le trône à la fin Marvel nous
a bien tisé d'ailleurs bien que timely
soit là pour son Nora temporel afin de
sauver le TVA son véritable
aboutissement semble être ce qui
s'apparente à la Time chare le fameux
siège temporel de Kang le conquérant qui
lui permet de voyager à travers tout le
multivers comme dévoilé dans htman
quantouania timely serait donc
simplement un Kang en devenir comme la
plupart de ces autres variants et
d'ailleurs si l'on reprend le procédé
d'introduction de Victor timely il se
peut que Marvel répète ce schéma pour
nous introduire d'autres identités de
Kang le Conquérant en tant que variant
Mister griffon par exemple je pars loin
dans le délire mais cela pourrait être
un Variant lui aussi placé par celui qui
demeure pareil pour Iron lad qui est
d'ailleurs le fondateur des Young
Avengers timely en fait ici avec ses
origine vient d'ouvrir une porte nous
permettant de voir possiblement d'autres
identités qui auront leur utilité dans
le plan ultime de celui qui demeure
permettant par la suite d'amener la
guerre multiverselle et nous montrer à
quel point celui qui demeure est
supérieur en utilisant la vie de ces
autres variants pour se Isser au plus
haut tout est possible à l'heure
actuelle mais déjà nous verrons si
timely sera capable de stopper
l'effondrement du TVA cependant au vu de
la vision du futur que Loki a vécu dans
le premier épisode je mise actuellement
peu sur cette possibilité pour conclure
j'aimerais maintenant que l'on parle un
peu de la scène finale et notamment de
ravona rensleyer bon vous le savez
depuis le temps ravona c'est l'intérêt
amoureux de Kang dans les comics les
deux auront une grande relation et c'est
un peu malheureusement la seule utilité
du personnage du coup forcément ils ont
taquiné cette relation dans l'épisode
mais ravona est quand même bien
différente par rapport au comics où tout
comme on l'avait mentionné avec Mobius
et roboros et bien elle était très
secondaire ici le point central qui
résume ravona dans la série c'est
l'accès au pouvoir ravona était
puissante elle dictait le bon vouloir
des Gardiens du Temps pendant des
siècles elle dirigeait en quelque sorte
le TVA et aujourd'hui elle souhaite
retrouver cette place ce pouvoir et même
plus à la découverte de l'existence de
celui qui demeure à la fin de l'épisode
Miss minut enragé nous explique elle
connaît tous les secrets de celui qui
demeure dont un en particulier qui
pourrait mettre ravona très en colère je
sais que certains pensent qu'elle
pourrait être elle-même une variante de
celui qui demeure mais personnellement
je vous avoue que j'ai du mal à y croire
au vu de l'obsession du pouvoir qui
compose le caractère de ravona dans la
série je pense plutôt que Miss minut
fait référence à ça en fait Miss minut
comme elle l'a dit a vécu un nombre
incalculable de temps en compagnie de
celui qui demeure c'est-à-dire la
création du TVA la guerre multiverselle
puis l'éternité à la fin des temps
ravona quant à elle fait partie
simplement du TVA et comme on nous l'a
montré avec Mobius et d'autres membres
les employés du TVA ont déjà tous été
reset à plusieurs reprises soit en gros
avec la mémoire effacée or dans le
premier épisode Loki dans le passé
écoute un audio de celui qui demeure
faisant l'éloge de ravona lors de la
guerre multiverselle dont notamment le
fait que ce dernier aimerait vraiment
diriger à ses côtés je pense
personnellement qu'il est là le secret
qui doit mettre ravona en colère ravona
a vécu la guerre multiverselle et a été
un atout majeur pour la victoire elle a
permis à celui qui demeure d'accéder à
son trône sauf que elle dans tout ça
qu'a-t-elle obtenu rien qu'une simple
place au sein du TVA et avec en prime la
mémoire effacée elle aurait dû diriger
avec celui qui demeure mais en réalité
ce dernier l'a trahi et est resté seul à
la fin des temps avec mis minute il est
là pour moi le secret dans tous les cas
nous aurons les réponses dans les
prochains épisodes et sincèrement merci
à la série Loki enfin Marvel nous
repropose du teasing concernant Kang et
qu'est-ce que c'est hpant en vrai on se
dirige petit à petit vers du concret et
il était temps et d'ailleurs les trois
premiers épisodes de la saison 2
composent la majorité des trailers de la
série ce qui veut dire qu'à partir de
maintenant nous allons vers de la quasi
découverte totale et au vu de la
puissance de la première moitié de la
série il y a moyen que le reste de la
saison soit phénoménal j'espère que ma
vidéo vous a plu si c'est le cas vous
savez quoi faire le petit like le petit
abonnement le petit commentaire
n'hésitez surtout pas à rejoindre la
chaîne je suis encore assez discret pour
le moment sur Youtube car je ne pouvais
pas vraiment redévelopper la chaîne
comme je le voulais mais sachez que
c'est quelque chose qui va changer je me
concentre sur l'oki principalement pour
le moment mais de de l'autre côté je
vous prépare plusieurs vidéos afin de
revenir complètement sur la plateforme
et j'ai très hâte nous allons pouvoir
nous refaire plaisir imaginer de belles
théories faire de belles analyses comme
cellees-ci et surtout reparler de
l'univers des comics qui est tout
simplement passionnant il faut qu'on
fasse briller l'univers Marvel sur ce je
me suis un peu lâché avec ces tout trop
mais j'avais besoin de vous parler les
amis c'était arargorok que le lion heart
soit avec vous allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]